you want to frame it very precisely why
have we had 25 or 30 years of one bubble
of extraordinary proportions after
another starting with Japan in the late
1980s you had South Asia and mid 90s you
had the tech boom in the the late 90s
and of course three incredible
overlapping bubbles housing which peaked
in q2 of 06 finance and financial
leverage that peaked in q2 of 07 and
then arguably emerging markets which I
believe is an equally serious bubble
that basically came to an end in late
two thousand seven and early two
thousand two thousand and eight and one
of the questions we should ask is why
have there been so many bubbles and I
think the events of the last 22 months
perhaps will lessen the appeal of the of
the conventional answer to this which
for the last 20 years has been that one
cannot talk about bubbles that it's not
coherent to talk about them that you
know in to paraphrase Alan Greenspan the
bigger a bubble it is the harder it is
to see so there may be lots of little
bubbles but we can never see a big
bubble which is of course spatially a
very odd metaphor since one would think
that the bigger something is the easier
it is to see and I think I think the
question of these systemic distortions
is once again going to become a real
question in a way that it has not been
for a very long time
you